те що сьогодні робиться цим
законопроектом Це не про полегшення
надання статусу учаснико бойових дій це
про великого брата із оруелівського
твору
1984 це про стеження за всіма українцями
це про збір понаднормової інформації про
всіх українців про всіх чоловіків які
які підлягають мобілізації у мене іноді
просто складається враження що Ну
давайте ще запишемо в цей законопроект
кожному на лоба
привісити веб-камеру і ходити з нею
постійно от тоді він буде повністю
відповідати антиутопії оруела Але чи ми
будуємо демократичне суспільство чи ми
будуємо
авторитарну Утопію яка була написана для
того щоб налякати людей і ніколи в житті
не підійти до такого Ви зараз же лякаєте
людей таким майбутнім